[Music]
today's question comes from robert in
tennessee
to say the home selling market in
tennessee is hot is an understatement
but i also have heard it's the worst
time to buy a home for that very reason
the value of our home has gone up
considerably and my wife and i would
like to sell in order to upgrade to a
larger home is now the right time to
cash in our equity and make this
purchase
do you think it's a good question from
robert uh well he's saying the value of
his home has gone up and you know
everyone's has because it's a hot market
and so there's this fever to go well i
want to sell i can upgrade i can upgrade
but here's the problem when you go to
upgrade well now you're trying to buy a
house that is also appreciated in value
and so there's kind of a trade-off here
where you've got to go
what's the right move financially
regardless of where the market's at can
i afford that upgraded house is it a
wise move for us to do um you know
regardless of what your house is going
to sell for yeah the the problem with
selling at the top of the market is you
have to buy at the top of the market
the problem with selling in a frenzy to
market where there's 17 offers in two
days
is you have to buy in a frenzied market
where there's 17 offers
in two days
and so unless you are somehow for some
reason making a
some kind of a different move
where
you cash out now but use that money
later
or use it in a different way
then just to buy in a frenzied market
and sell in a frenzy market is
you know
it's frenzied hello
i mean high stress scenario to do it
right now
and so i think the breakdown at least in
the way you've worded your question the
breakdown in your wife's logic is
she sees that you can get a lot for your
house but hasn't considered that it's
going to take a lot to buy the next one
and so i don't think homes are going to
come down
they've gone way up but not artificially
it's just a drive it was an artificial
demand and it was a coveted supply
demand in the
in the
basically the new housing market the
supply chain got screwed up because the
lumber market and a few other markets
they couldn't get houses out of the
ground and labor market
couldn't get houses out of the ground
and that slowed up and created a supply
demand problem meaning there was a
shortage of housing and that drove this
market and created a little bit of
artificial inflation but i don't think
next year houses are going to come down
i don't think the year after that
they're going to come down
and why do i think that
because i got my real estate license in
1978
and if you look back on the real estate
market since 1950 so 75 years
you've not seen houses go down
in value in 75 years year over year
except in a few markets once
and that was 2008.
when there was a housing bubble
and there was a a real problem a housing
economic crisis this is not a housing
economic crisis this is an overall
supply chain screw-up due to covet
and
the economic suppression that came along
with making everyone sit in their homes
on their thumbs
and it screwed up the economy
now you can argue about the medical part
of it or not but you can't really argue
about the economic part of it it screwed
up the economy
making people sit at home and not work
screwed up the economy straight up okay
so
would you buy and sell a house this year
only if you want the stress of selling
in a frenzy market and buying in a
forensic market
i don't worry about the height of the
prices as much as i do the process the
process to sell a typical home today
is you're basically having an auction
the process for buying a typical home
today is you're basically having an
auction and that is a high stress
scenario for most people and people end
up doing things they regret later in
high stress scenarios so
unless you've got a situation where you
can move i'm moving this year but i sold
a ridiculously large house that really
would have been very tough to sell in
any kind of market other than this
and i thought you know what god if you
want to sell this house i've had fun
with it for 12 years this sounds like a
really good time to get out and i got
out
and i cashed out but i'm doing something
different there than just moving from
house to house to house to house you
know about my house but it's not nowhere
near as big and all this and so
we didn't even say we need to downsize
we didn't say that we said hey we're
going to cash out at the top on this and
we'll just buy something over here
that's a little different than i want to
move up and and neither one of the homes
we bought are typical either oh yeah and
also our team the ramsey research team
just released the q2 state of personal
finance study and they found that the
majority of people are waiving
inspections and appraisals because of
how crazy it is they are way overpaying
above asking price i'm not talking about
two thousand dollars more we're talking
50
thousand dollars above asking to get a
guy on our team sold at 750 000 house
the other day 120 000 above market and
he took one of the 22 offers oh my
goodness
and that was about a month and that's
what they're going to be dealing with if
they sell this house well now they've
got a whole another situation over here
so i don't think it's this hey the
housing market's hot let's all sell
right now it's it's not going to work
out like that well i mean
if you're going if you got someplace
else to live until the thing cools off
that's okay but uh to buy and the
repurchasing of it is the problem in
most people's situation right now i will
tell you this too
in the last 90 days the market has
calmed down considerable
i'd say the activity is about half of
what it was in middle tennessee
it's still very hot but it was
white hot frenzied 90 days ago yeah that
story i just told you was about 90 days
ago that that happened